on Wednesday Michael Harriet of the
route calm and a shocking piece titled
everything you think you know about the
death of Mike Brown is wrong and the man
who killed him admits it provocative
Sally clone of CNN she have hands up
don't shoot fame tweeted out the article
with this caption we all need to read
and reckon with how our media courts
everything believes white cops lies over
black kids truth oh which means that
you'd think the article would actually
substantiate the headline after all most
people think Michael Brown attacked a
police officer Darren Wilson inside his
vehicle after being pulled over then
tried to grab the officer's gun then ran
when a shot was fired in the car before
turning around charging the cop and
being shot that's when all the witness
testimony said repeatedly from black
witnesses so what did Officer Wilson say
that changed everything according to the
root com reporting on the court
documents originally obtained by Wesley
Lowery of the Washington Post a guy who
by the way reported in lavatory terms
about the unrest in Ferguson it's time
Wilson stated that he reached through
the window his car and grabbed for
Brown's body during the encounter of
course Wilson never said anything
different he always maintained Brown
punch him in the face at which point he
grabbed it brown is brown leaned into
the car he pulled his gun Brown
attempted to grab his gun he fired his
gun in the rest of the events ensued but
here's how the route describes the
events two men are walking down the
street a cop pulls in front of them
blocking their path instead of calling
for backup or radioing in a traffic stop
he opens his cards or neither Brown
closed it or ricochets off of Brown's
body the officer then chooses to reach
through his window and grab the suspect
by his arm and body Wilson had a gun and
brown is hanging inside the car browses
not reached for the officer's gun and
the cop admits that brown's only weapon
was his big scary black self the next
part of the testimony will confound the
conservatives who stated that wilson did
not shoot Brown in the back Wilson admit
that after the first shot Brown started
running away from him and he fired
another shot which Miss Brown Wilson
basically admits that he fired at Brown
and the bullet hitting a building close
by then the root alleges that Wilson
admits having used the n-word other
headlines have repeated this they
neglect to mention that Wilson
explicitly says he only used the n-word
or in order to repeat a quote racist
remark made by someone else but I have
not made a racist remark against another
individual while on duty as a police
officer unquote oops but what about the
rest of this narrative it's just not
true Wilson doesn't admit any of the
things the roots as he admits as Wesley
Lauer himself tweeted here's what Lowry
tweeted there are
answered Ferguson questions but a lot of
assertions in this piece going viral
today based on the doc I reported
yesterday are wrong the court documents
reveal none of these things Wilson has
asked specific questions he's not asked
others can't infer entire narrative by
filling in the blanks based on things
he's not asked Wilson admit that Browns
did not try to remove your gun from your
holster this is not the same as
admitting Brown never reached for the
gun nowhere in this document is Wilson
address who initiated contact admits at
some point he reached through window
doesn't address the timeline there is
nothing I've seen in December twentieth
admissions from Darren Wilson that
materially altars and contradicts his
previous version of the story Lowry is
honest and reports this correctly I've
read the entire document it is clear
that the route and by proxy Sally Kohn
are confabulating Wilson's testimony
into a story of their own making a
narrative repeatedly debunked by
third-party witnesses and the Department
of Justice itself which found no
wrongdoing by Wilson this is how leftist
narrative spread and there will be
violence burn on by such narratives
because the hard left likes is riots
just so long as the riots are aimed at
the establishment meaning in this case
the cops I'm Ben Shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
well today's mail bag day and that's
very exciting we be doing that a little
bit later which is why you need to
become a subscriber over at daily
wire.com we're also going to be talking
I'm going to break down this awful awful
court decision from a judge in a federal
district judge in Hawaii striking down
or at least putting a temporary hold on
Donald Trump's executive president
Trump's executive order on immigration
and refugees I will break that down for
you awful awful decision and I read the
decision twice because it's so bad but
it took twice just to comprehend all the
stupidity inherent in it but first we
have to say thank you to our friends and
sponsors over at lift so if you need to
go somewhere and you're looking for the
best a ride-sharing app there is list is
it and you try to lift you know what I
mean it's high quality drivers all the
cars are new they show up in three and a
half minutes on average every lyft
driver is fully vetted through a 10
point safety standard including criminal
and DMV background checks you know
you're going to get around quickly and
safely we use lifts all the time in my
family I use it my wife uses it more
important to me that my wife uses it
because sometimes she's coming home late
from the hospital she's really tired and
as a young and beautiful woman it is
important to me that my wife is picked
up by people who I know that I can trust
with safety and same thing for her and
that's why she uses lift you can also
type in the app which means that the
drivers are happier nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating
from the passenger it's a better
all-around experience the quality is
really really high in right now if you
download the lift app and you use promo
code Shapiro you get up to three free
ride you three free rides up to ten
dollars each a thirty dollar value when
you're enter promo code Shapiro so go
download the app right now the lift app
lyf d lift promo code Shapiro and again
you get a thirty dollar value three free
rides up to ten dollars each promo code
Shapiro and it is the best ride-sharing
app there is lift and we thank them for
being our sponsors obviously use that
promo code Shapiro in order to get the
discount also to let them know that were
the ones who sent you okay so the one of
the worst judicial decisions in recent
memory came out yesterday from a
district court judge in Hawaii and he
struck down Donald Trump's revised
executive order now we didn't really
talk too much about Donald Trump's
revised executive order because
basically what the revised executive
order on immigration and refugees did is
it got rid of a lot of the things that
the Ninth Circuit objected to and the
federal
court in Washington objected to
originally in the first executive order
so first things first the first
executive order was fully constitutional
and it was fully legal but the Court
struck it down anyway they said that it
affected green card holders which was a
problem they said that it was
religiously discriminatory which really
shouldn't have been a problem but they
said it was so the new version got rid
of all language with regards to Islam
and Christianity the new version got rid
of its application to green card holders
the new version broadened the ability
for the Secretary of State's grant
admission to people on the basis of
exceptions to the rules set up it's a
facially neutral statute meaning it has
no differentiation between Muslims and
anybody else that didn't stop the court
so this federal district judge basically
decides and this is basically what the
decision comes down so it's an amazing
thing the decision comes down to I don't
like Donald Trump therefore the
executive order is bad and that is not
much of a simplification the entire
decision rests on the idea that he's not
actually going to read the verbiage is
not going to read the actual wording of
the executive order instead they're just
going to look at stuff that Donald Trump
has said over the past two years and say
look it looks like Donald Trump doesn't
like Muslims therefore even though this
particular executive order doesn't
discriminate against Muslims even though
this particular executive order only
applies to people from six of the most
terror rich countries on earth
originally named by Barack Obama we're
still going to impute to Donald Trump
some sort of nefarious motives to ban
Muslims because he doesn't like Muslims
so in other words we're not going to
look at the wall we're going to look at
what they said about the law but not
even what they said about this while
we're going to look at what he said a
year ago about different stuff and now
if the court had held this about
Obamacare Obamacare would have been
struck down obviously Obamacare should
have been struck down anyway because
Obama was telling the truth when he said
Obamacare was not attacked it was a fee
but the court specifically ignored
Obamacare being a fee and not attacked
in order to rewrite the statute and
protect the Obamacare so they ignored
everything Obama said in order to ensure
that Barack Obama's signature law remain
law in this case they're taking
something that is obviously and
perfectly legal and they are saying that
it is now illegal because they don't
like what Donald Trump said so let's go
through some of the Dumber things about
this decision and it is demonstrative of
the fact that Congress means to crack
down on the jurisdiction of federal
courts federal courts should not have
this type of jurisdiction
and circuit should be broken up as a as
a circuit court of appeals there's a
long-standing opinion of mine this is
not something that is brought about by
this particular decision i wrote my
entire third year law paper at harvard
law which i've been attempting to dig up
for a while now i wrote the entire thing
on why judicial review is a
constitutional error and why actually
has nothing to do with the constitution
of the united states that said this
decision is perfect evidence of why you
cannot have a group of judges who think
they are an oligarchic super legislature
oh good they think their lawmakers
they're not lawmakers so what does this
actual decision say well first it says
that the Constitution bars religious
discrimination against foreigners it
says the Establishment Clause applies to
people who don't even live in the
country not it doesn't apply to American
citizens alone it applies to some random
dude on a hilltop and Yemen so in other
words if you have a policy that says
random dude on a hilltop in Yemen we're
not letting you in because you are a
radical Muslim they say well this would
violate the Establishment Clause because
you obviously prefer Christians to
Muslims this is asinine first of all the
provisions of the Constitution do not
apply to foreigners the Constitution
only applies to people who are citizens
of the United States not apply to people
who are living any random place in the
world if the Constitution has to grant
rights to people to immigrate regardless
of religion regardless of viewpoint when
you imagine this again the First
Amendment of the Constitution also says
you have freedom of speech it says you
have freedom of religion and it has the
Establishment Clause the government
cannot establish religion so let's say
the constitution were to apply to people
all over the world and out applies to
everyone well the first amendment also
says you have freedom of speech so that
means that presumably that applies to
anybody abroad and those people we can't
discriminate against them based on
viewpoint right the government is not
allowed viewpoint discrimination against
you or me and can't shut me down because
of what I'm saying if we took the same
logic that this Court is applying to the
Establishment Clause and applied it to
the free speech Clause what you'd end up
with is anyone anywhere on earth has a
right to enter the United States no
matter what they think about things okay
that's how crazy this court decision is
other things that this decision says as
I say the court actually says that
motivation matters not text explicitly
acknowledged explicitly acknowledged
that there is nothing in this executive
order that discriminates against Muslims
they then
try to make the claim that it
discriminates against Muslims even
though clearly does not discriminate
against all Muslims the court says the
illogic of the government's contentions
is palpable the notion that one can
demonstrate animus toward any group of
people only by targeting all of them at
once is fundamentally flawed hey that
doesn't make any sense at all if you're
demonstrating animus for a group of
people obviously you have to demonstrate
animus for the entire group of people if
I have a law and it only affects a
certain percentage of black people but
it doesn't affect 99% of black people
it's very difficult to say that the law
is actually motivated by animus against
black people that seems relatively
logical to me and in fact the court then
goes on to make exactly the same case
that they're saying is the logical right
there then say this is obviously a
Muslim ban because it applies to
countries that are largely Muslim you
can't make a statistical already put
like that if you're just claiming the
statistical arguments are irrelevant to
the question of animus they quote Donald
Trump from March 2016 saying I think
Islam hates us again March 2016 he was
still a candidate he wasn't even
president then they quote Trump's
infamous Muslim ban press release from
late 2015 and they say all of this is
the backdrop to this executive order and
then they say that because Donald Trump
says mean things about the Muslims that
means that the executive order is
illegal and then they quote the Tenth
Circuit on this issue and here's what
they say they basically say that maybe
at some future point he could pass the
exact same executive order and we
wouldn't strike it down we wouldn't put
a temporary restraining order on it
because we would we would know that he
actually is not a mean guy so now
they're judging Trump is a person he's a
mean guy right this is what they say
from the above principles we conclude
that a government cure should be one
purposeful to public and three at least
as persuasive as the initial endorsement
of religion it should be purposeful
enough for an objective observer to know
unequivocally that the government does
not endorse religion so in other words
if Donald Trump spends the next two
years talking about how Islam is just
awesome then they might allow him to
pursue this executive order but until
then until he goes out and says publicly
that Islam is the best religion that
ever was and he loves Islam like no
other that is a big league in his own
words until he actually does that they
are going to ban this executive order
they're going to mind-read Donald Trump
which is a challenging thing under any
circumstances it's particularly stupid
when the people attempting to mind-read
Trump are obviously not mind reading
Trump
mind-reading themselves in their
perceptions about Trump okay other
things that are idiotic about this
decision so they reinforce in this
decision this notion pushed by the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals in that federal
district judge in Washington that a
state is able to sue and get immigration
policy held up if it doesn't benefit the
state to have more immigration so the
state says one of the big issues in
lowering is something called standing I
can't sue the government based on some
random law that doesn't affect me I
can't assume Mathis today based on the
fact that I get food poisoning from a
separate restaurant I don't have
standing because Mathis hasn't done me
any harm right you have to get a
standing mean that the person you're
suing has some connection with a harm
that is that is being inflicted upon you
so what the court does here is they
broaden the issue of standing because
really the state doesn't have any
standing to sue the federal government
based on immigration policy they don't
if they could then presumably the state
of Arizona could have sued the federal
government long ago for not enforcing
its immigration laws affecting the state
of Arizona and negative ways they
weren't able to but now the court finds
standing to open the borders why because
universities in states like Hawaii
wouldn't be able to recruit that viewed
on the hilltop in Yemen seriously this
is what it says it says that the state
has preliminary demonstrated that its
universities will suffer monetary
damages and intangible harms so now we
are now measuring the state standing
based on in tangible harm things that
kept you measured or felt okay that's
totally insane as well and then finally
I think that the most insane the most
insane thing here of all I'll tell you
in one second but first I have to say
thank you to our advertisers over at sea
so so they have a new series out that
actually really really funny when called
shrink when it's about a guy from five
hundred thousand dollars in debt after
going to med school and instead of
actually starting a real practice he
starts conducting free therapy sessions
for patients that he finds on craigslist
and the series is really really funny
now you should go check it out right now
it's critically acclaimed you can watch
the trailer over a YouTube of the series
is called shrimp well you can only do
that you can only I should watch the
series if you subscribe to see so so see
so is your one stop shop for all comedy
see so has backlogs of the office is
has bath logs of Parks and Rec has
backlogs all the british comedies like
the office and and and all of month you
Python it has all the late night shows
we're going to play some late night
later some of the late night is getting
really good now actually so go to see so
calm and subscribe it's just 3 99 per
month no joke and it has all the comedy
that you would ever want see so calm SE
ESO calm and you get one month free if
you use promo code bets you can try it
out risk-free see if you like it see so
calm promo club and my wife and I really
really do enjoy see so we watch it
almost every night because it is
hilarious and the amount of comedy
content is astounding they have the
entire backlog of Saturday Night Live
going back to the days when it didn't
suck so go and check it out right now
see so calm and become a subscriber for
3 99 per month and you can access their
content from everything including Amazon
fire and Apple TV or Android or iOS you
can get it anywhere so check it out see
so calm and remember use that promo clip
been at checkout so that you can number
one signal that you listen to the show
and number two so you can actually get
that one month for free and see if you
like it ok so the stupidest thing of all
about this about this ruling well I
should say the second stupidest thing
the stupidest thing as this whole
feelings routine this this routine that
Donald Trump's feelings about Islam
shape how the court rules on an
executive order I'll tell you the reason
that that's the stupidest thing the
reason that's the stupidest thing is if
people can now sue the president of the
United States and say that he is
violating the Establishment Clause
simply because he has quote unquote
animus for some group outside the united
states that violates the Establishment
Clause then you could theoretically have
somebody sued Trump to stop him from
pursuing military action against like
al-qaeda and Isis because he doesn't
really hate all Qaeda and Isis he hates
all of this long right they could use
exactly the same logic they're using
right now on immigration well I think
they're using on immigration Trump says
I want to stop al Qaeda I want to stop
by since I'm gonna stop terrorists from
coming into the country and they say no
what you really mean is you hate Muslims
why couldn't you use that exact same
logic with regard to what he's doing it
more why couldn't you say well what he
really means is he doesn't hate al Qaeda
or Isis he hates all Muslims you want to
war with Islam and that means I'm going
to sue him because the Establishment
Clause doesn't allow him to make policy
to discriminate based on religion okay
this is crazy talk the stupidest thing
however is this is
the second stupidest thing in this
ruling however is the granting of
standing to the plaintiff atty named dr.
ismail el sheikh okay dr. el sheikh is
an american citizen of egyptian descent
there are two issues that make him not
right for standing here the don't grant
him standing in this case one he's an
American citizen the executive order
does not apply to American citizens to
hes from egypt it doesn't apply to
Egyptians Egypt is not one of the
countries on the list so there are two
separate reasons why he is so number one
he's an American citizen it doesn't
apply to him to even if it didn't apply
to American citizens it still wouldn't
apply to him because hes from egypt so
who does it apply to he's suing because
his mother-in-law is from syria and she
wants to come visit seriously his mother
first of all this alone should mean that
he never gets tanjung because no one
wants their mother-in-law to visit but
second of all the idea that he's getting
standing based on his mother-in-law
living in Syria's insane how does the
court come up with the idea of standing
they say he has standing because his
direct quote he thinks that the
executive order is devastating to me my
wife and children since it saddened him
I am NOT making that up that is in the
court decision the court decision says
that this guy has standing to sue the
federal government because the policy of
the federal government made him sad okay
I am now going to see the federal
government for everyone and regulation
in his past in the last 20 years because
they all make me sad because they all
suck it doesn't work that way this is
not how law works this is a usurpation
skort there's a court that is you
surfing obviously the power of the of
the presidency and it's about time for
Congress to step in and do something
about it because this is fully crazy
this is fully crazy we'll talk more
about that will also do the mailbag but
in order for you to do that and see that
you're going to have to go over to daily
wire calm and become a subscriber you go
over today lee weyer comet eight bucks a
month allows you access to watch the
rest of the podcast live and in living
color you can become part of the mail
back to you don't get your answer your
questions answered unless you are one of
the members of our special special
coterie of geniuses and you only become
part of that coder you only get your
special decoder badge when you go to
decoder ring when you go to daily wire
calm and you become a subscriber for
eight dollars a month you can become an
annual subscriber as well right now we
are giving out copies of the runaway
bestseller reasons to vote down
by Michael moles this is the this is the
book that is soaring it's still number
one on amazon it's the number one on
amazon for a week and a half and it is
literally a blank book of pages but you
get a free copy of it because it is it
is hilarious i did and i will take
partial credit because I put my quote on
the front of his thorough in any case
you get a free copy of that when you
become the annual subscriber and and
Michael will sign it for you he'll be
happy to sign it for you since he
obviously has nothing better to do like
write actual books so go over today lee
weyer calm right now and become an
annual subscriber you get that for free
plus I promise I keep saying this the
Shapiro store is coming there will be
discounts for subscribers and you can go
and check that out over at daily wire
calm or later listen to the rest of the
show at itunes and soundcloud and leave
a rating over at itunes we are the top
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you